[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من القدس وهذه الصور المباشره
لجنود اسرائيليين محتجين على تغييرات
القضائيه المزمن
وهذه الصور من اعلان القوات الاوكرانيه
قصف اهداف عسكريه في شبه جزيره القرن مع
توعد بالمزيد من الهجمات
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصعيد غير مسبوق في ازمه التغييرات
القضائيه في اسرائيل اكثر من نصف مليون
شخص يشاركون في الاحتجاجات قبل ساعات من
تصويت الكنيست بالقراءه الاخيره على مشروع
قانون يقلص صلاحيات المحكمه العليا وبعد
اعلان اكثر من عشره الاف عسكري احتياط
انضمامهم الى مئات طياري الاحتياط في
الامتناع عن الخدمه العسكريه رئيس الاركان
يطلب لقاء نتنياهو ويحذر من ضرر حقيقي على
كفاءه الجيش خلال اليومين المقبلين اذا
مررت التغييرات
وسط هجمات اوكرانيه متزايده على مواقع
استراتيجيه في شبه جزيره القرن دياف تتوعد
بالمزيد وتقول ان موسم الانفجارات في
القرن بدا ومع اتهام موسكو واشنطن
بالمسؤوليه عن الضربه الاوكرانيه بذخائر
عنقوديه في بلغورود مسؤولون امريكيون
يعلنون تمسك اداره بايدن برفضها تزويد
ثياب بصواريخ بعيده المدى وفي ازمه تصدير
الحبوب زيلينسكي يقول انه اتفق مع الامين
العام للناتو على فتح ممر في البحر الاسود
وتشغيله بشكل مستدام
في السودان قصف للجيش على اهداف للدعم
السريع في جنوب الخرطوم وشرقها ومسيرات
الدعم السريع تقصف مواقع للجيش في ام
درمان وفي جنوب كردفان معارك جديده بين
الجيش وقوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا اعلان الاف من العسكريين الاحتياط
في اسرائيل الامتناع عن الخدمه احتجاجا
على تغييرات القضائيه لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم كيف تنعكس هذه
الخطوه على موقف حكومه نتنياهو من
التعديلات القضائيه
35% قالوا انها ستجبر الحكومه على تراجع
بينما راى 37% انها ستدفعها للتفاوض على
حل وسط اما ثمانيه وعشرون في المئه فتوقع
استمرار الحكومه في التغييرات القضائيه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وسط مصاعب اقتصاديه ومخاوف امنيه السلطات
التشاديه تنقل اللاجئين السودانيين من
منطقه الحدوديه الى منطقه اورنج ومنظمات
انسانيه تناشد بتمويل برامج اغاثه
[موسيقى]
اذا في تصعيد غير مسبوق في ازمه التغييرات
القضائيه في اسرائيل اعلن منظمه
الاحتجاجات ضد التغييرات ان نحو
50000 شخص شاركوا في المظاهرات الليله
منهم
240 الفا في تل ابيب ونحو 100 الف في
القدس والباقون في مدن حيفا
ونتانيا واكفر سابا وبئر السبع والكثير من
المناطق هذه التظاهرات تاتي استعدادا
للمشاركه في احتجاجات امام مقر الكنيست
غدا الاحد رفضا لتغييرات قضائيه تحاول
حكومه نتنياهو تمريرها ويصفها المحتجون
بالانقلاب القضائي وحذرت المعارضه
الاسرائيليه مما وصفته بمحاولات الاستبداد
بالحكم واقرار تغييرات تهدف لتخليص
نتنياهو من قضايا فساد يحاكم فيها امام
القضاء
ونقلت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه عن
رئيس اركان الجيش تحذيره من ضرر حقيقي على
كفاءه الجيش خلال الساعات 48 المقبله في
حال تمرير التغييرات القضائيه وفي السياق
ذاته ايد رؤساء سابقون لهيئه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وجهازي الموساد
اعلان مئات العسكريين في قوات الاحتياط
امتناعهم عن التطوع في الخدمه العسكريه
الاحتياطيه في حال مررت الحكومه مشاريعها
القانونيه لتغيير النظام القضائي
ونقلت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
كبار المسؤولين في الاجهزه الامنيه حذروا
من ان ما تقوم به حكومه نتنياهو شديد
الخطوره على النسيج الاجتماعي في اسرائيل
ومن شانه شق الشيء الجيش والشعب على نحو
لا يمكن توقع تداعياته السلبيه واتاحه
المجال لاستبداد يميني عقائدي متطرف على
حد قولهم
ينضم الينا من القدس مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد انقل لنا الاجواء عشيه
اجتماع الكنيست
نحن انتقلنا ووصلنا قبل لحظات الى الموقع
قبلت الكنيست في هذا الميدان حيث نصب
المئات من المحتجين خيم للبقاء فيها في
هذه الليله
ليباشروا احتجاجاتهم منذ ساعات صباح غدا
حيث متوقع ان يكون هناك حراك كبير في هذه
المنطقه مع بدء الكنيست
جلسته جلسه هيئته العامه المخصصه للمصادقه
على احد القوانين الخاصه بتقليص الصلاحيات
المحكمه العليا
المظاهره التي كانت في القدس هذه الليله
والتي انتهت قبل لحظات كانت في منطقه مجمع
رئاسه الوزراء والمحكمه العليا والكنيست
واستمرت لبعض الوقت كانت قد بدات بمسيره
وصلت من المدن ومن تل ابيب تحديدا مضى
عليه نحو ثلاثه ايام حتى وصلت والتقديرات
ان نحو 100 قد شاركوا فيها المنظمون
يتحدثون عن ان المظاهرات الاخرى واكبرها
كانت في تل ابيب قد شارك فيها نحو 240
الفا وان مجموع ما شارك في مظاهرات هذه
الليله تحديدا قد تجاوز ال 500 وخمسين
الفا من المحتجين الاسرائيليين الذين
يطالبون بوقفي والغاء هذه التشريعات التي
يعمل عليها نتنياهو او على الاقل الا تتم
الا بالوفاق التطورات الاخرى التي لحقت
ذلك ان
ازداد عدد العسكري الاحتياط الذين اعلنوا
بانهم سيمتنعون عن الخدمه الاحتياط اذا ما
استدعوا اليها وفي مؤتمر صحفي في اعلن عن
قائمه من نحو عشره الاف من العسكريين
والجنود اضافه الى اكثر من 1100 من سلاح
الجو بين طيارينا وفنينا يعملون في سلاح
الجو في الاحتياط بالاضافه الى ايضا
عاملين في قطاعات مثل الاستخبارات
العسكريه واجهزه الامن الاخرى وكان هناك
بيان موقع من قاده ورؤساء سابقين سواء
لهيئه الاركان العسكريه او للجهازي المساد
والشباك الذين حملوا نتنياهو نتيجه ما
يجري وانه يتسبب في تفسيخ الشارع
الاسرائيلي واضعاف الجيش والتطور الاخير
كان بان رئيس هيئه الاركان العسكريه
قد طلب اجتماعا عاجلا مع نتنياهو سيتم غدا
وذلك على خلفيه تزايد ظاهره
العسكريه الذي يعلنون بانهم سيمتنعون عن
الذهاب الى الخدمه الاحتياط وهي خدمه
تطوعيه في الاساس لكنها عاده لا يرفضونها
يقومون بها في كل الوقت التطورات المتوقعه
غدا مع اجتماع الهيئه العامه للكنيسه
الاسرائيلي بالساعه العاشره صباحا
حيث تتواصل جلسته ليومين على الاقل حتى
يوم الاثنين مساء ان المحتجين والمعارضين
سيحتجدون في هذه المنطقه ومناطق اخرى لكن
بدات احزاب اليمين الائتلاف اليمين الحاكم
المناصريه نتنياهو ايضا تدعو لمظاهره اخرى
في نفس هذه المنطقه في ساعات مساء يوم غد
والشرطه تعلن انها ستغلق العديد من
الشوارع في محيطها
شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره
حدثنا من القدس
مظاهرات كل اسبوع في اسرائيل ضد التعديلات
القضائيه لم تثني هذه المظاهرات الائتلاف
الحاكم بقياده بنيامين طنياهو عن
الاستعداد بالتصويت في القراءه الثالثه
والنهائيه على قانون ضمن حزمه قوانين اخرى
هدفها تقليص صلاحيات المحكمه العليا
بالنسبه للاستهلاك الحاكم تهدف التعديلات
الى تصحيح ما يراه حاله عدم توازن بين
السلطه القضائيه واعضاء البرلمان
المنتخبين اما معارض الخطه فيرون ان هدفها
اعطاء الائتلاف الحاكم سلطه مطلقه وتحقيق
اهدافه ومنها ومنح اعضاء الكنيست والوزراء
ورئيس الوزراء حصانه اثناء توليهم مناصبهم
وهكذا يفلت نتنياهو من الملاحقات القضائيه
في قضايا فساد وبذلك يضمن الائتلاف
استمراره في الحكم كما تسعى الاحزاب التي
تمثل اليهود المتشددين الى تمرير قانون
يعفيهم من الخدمه العسكريه ولذلك تريد
تجريد المحكمه العليا من سلطه الغاء مثل
هذا القانون
اكثر من ذلك تطمح للسماح لشخصيات منها سبق
ان اذينت بتهم مختلفه بتولي مناصب وزاريه
مثل زعيم حزب حركه شاص الذي ابعد من
الحكومه لتحقيق هذه الاهداف تركز
التعديلات على تقليص السلطه المحكمه
العليا اولا من خلال تشريع يسمح بالغاء
قراراتها باغلبيه يسيره اي 61 صوتا من 120
وبهذا ستفقد المحكمه جزءا كبيرا من سلطتها
ومنها القدره على الغاء اي تشريع يتناقض
مع قوانين الاساس التي تقوم مقام الدستور
في اسرائيل فخلال 30 عاما الماضيه الغت
المحكمه العليا 22 تشريعا سنها الكنيست ما
يظهر السلطه التي تتمتع بها حاليا اما
الوسيله الثانيه للحد من قوه المحكمه فهي
تغيير تشكيله اللجنه اختيار قضاتها تضم
اللجنه حاليا تسعه اعضاء ثلاثه قضاه من
المحكمه العليا ومحاميين ووازيرين وعضوين
في الكنيست ويتطلب تعيين اي قائد في
المحكمه العليا موافقه سبعه من الاعضاء
التسعه وهو امر يجعل من الصعب ان يكون صوت
السياسيين اي الوزراء واعضاء الكنيست في
اختيار قضاه المحكمه اعلى من صوت الاعضاء
المهنيين من القضاه والمحامين اما خطه
التعديلات فتنص على توسيع اللجنه لتضم احد
عشر عضوا باضافه عضو من الكنيست ووزير على
ان يتخلص عدد الاصوات المطلوبه لتعيين
قائد في المحكمه الى سته وهكذا يزيد عدد
اصحاب المناصب السياسيه على حساب اصحاب
المناصب المهنيه يرى معارض خطه التعديلات
ان تمريرها سيجعل قرارات الحكومه والوزراء
خارج نطاق عمل المحكمه العليا في نظام
تتداخل فيه السلطتان التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
ما يعني انهاء الفصل بين السلطات في دوله
لا يوجد فيها دستور
انا من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك المحاضر
في العلوم السياسيه والخبير في شؤون
الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك سيد سليم الى اين
تتجه هذه الازمه في اسرائيل بعدما وصلت
الى الفصل الاخير على ما يبدو
مساء الخير اخ حسن لك جميع المشاهدين طبعا
نحن ننتظر لنرى امامنا 40 ساعه لنعرف
تماما كيف ستنتهي هذه الازمه ولكن نحن
نتحدث عن واحده من اهم
واكثر الازمات حده منذ قيام دوله اسرائيل
لانه الموضوع لا يتعلق فقط في الانقلاب
القضائي هذا عمليا محاوله لتغيير مبنى
دوله اسرائيل حتى من الناحيه الاجتماعيه
الثقافيه يعني القوانين المتتابعه التي
تريد هذه المجموعه تمريرها هي قوانين اولا
تتماشى مع المبنى الفاشي لهذه الحكومه نحن
نتحدث عن الحكومه التي المركبات فيها
الهامه هي الصهيونيه الدينيه والحريدين
القضيه الثانيه هي طبعا
سيطرت السلطه القضائيه على السلطه
التشريعيه وعلى المحكمه بشكل مطلق نحن
الان نتحدث عن سلطه تنفيذيه تسيطر بشكل
مطلق على السلطه التشريعيه
وفصل السلطات ضعيف جدا في اسرائيل وطبعا
لا يوجد دستور فاذا هذا موضوع مهم جدا
الموضوع الاخر هو عمليا كل واجهه دوله
اسرائيل يعني عمليه شرعنت الفساد كما نرى
مثلا من خلال قانون معقوليه الذي يصرون
على تمريره حتى مع كل هذه التهديدات وكل
هذه الاجراءات
باختصار هنا هل الحل الوسط
ممكن من الان حتى يوم غد
باعتقاد انه الحكومه تستعمل استراتيجيه
تشيكن جيم يعني مع المعارضه ونحن سمعنا
مثلا اثنين على الاقل من وزراء الائتلاف
وزراء الكابينات الامني يقولون بان
القوانين القانون سيمر كما هو ولن يكون
هناك اي تغيير في القانون وعلى ما يبدو ان
نتنياهو مصر او مجبر بواسطه وزير القضاء
والحريدين على تمرير القانون كما هو ماذا
لو تمريره كما هو الاسرائيليه اربعين ساعه
هو فتره طويله جدا قد يتغير فيها شيء ولكن
اربعين ساعه قد يتغير فيها الكثير يعني
ولكن ولكن سؤال ماذا لو مررت فعلا هناك
الكثير من الضغوطات هذا واضح
اعتقادي انه هذا سيكون اجتياز خط احمر
الشرق في المجتمع الاسرائيلي هو عميق جدا
وهو في جميع القطاعات يعني مثلا حاليا في
اللحظات التي نتحدث فيها منظمه العمال
الاسرائيليه تدخل ايضا الى على الخط الى
التصعيد وربما سيكون هناك طبعا
تصعيد من قبل قطاعات اخرى في في المجتمع
قسم كبير من اصحاب رؤوس الاموال واصحاب
الشركات الكبرى الان انضموا الى التظاهرات
نحن سمعنا كمان رؤساء الاستخبارات ورؤساء
الجيش اكثر من 100 ضابط علي الرتبه
انضموا الى هذه
التظاهرات ولكن على ما يبدو ان الحكومه
مصره لان نتنياهو ظهره الى الحائط يعني هو
لا يستطيع ان يقوم بشيء اخر طالما هو
محكوم من قبل الحديدين والصهيونيه الدينيه
من ناحيه
وملفاته الفساد التي يحاكم عليها من ناحيه
اخرى
ما خطوره
ما ذهب اليه الاف من جنود الاحتياط وايضا
من سلاح الجو
الاحتياط ما خطورته على الجيش تحديدا
طبعا هناك خطوره كبيره طبعا ليس بعلى
مستوى عمليات يوميه او مثلا عمليات محدوده
ولكن اذا كانت هناك مثلا حرب في الفتره
القريبه هذا سيؤثر بشكل كبير جدا لانه نحن
شايفين 594 الطيار وقعوا بانهم لن يستمروا
في التطوع طبعا التطوع في في سلاح الجو
وفي الاستخبارات مثلا في السجن في
الثمانيه 200 والى اخره
وحدات اللي فيها عدم التطوع يمس بجاهزيه
الجيش بشكل ملموس ولذلك هناك خطر حقيقي
طبعا
والكابينات او اعضاء من الكابينات يحاولون
تخفيف من حده هذا الخطر ولكن على ما يبدو
ان رئيس الاركان والقائد العام للجيش
موجودين ايضا تحت ضغوطات من الضباط بانهم
يجب ان ينقلوا الصوره الحقيقيه لرئيس
الحكومه وليس كما يريدها بعض اعضاء
الكابينات او بعض الشخصيات المعنيه بتمرير
القانون باي ثمن شكرا لك الدكتور سليم
بريك المحاضر في العلوم السياسيه والخبير
في شؤون الاسرائيليه من الناصره شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه انها نفذت هجوما
على مستودعي اسلحه ونفط للجيش الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم وكان حاكم القرن الموالي
لروسيا قد اكد وقوع الهجوم ما تسبب بوقوع
انفجارات في المستودع وقال المسؤول الروسي
ان القصف لم يسفر عن وقوع اصابات وانه جرى
اجلاء جميع السكان من المناطق المتاخمه
للمستودع وقد اعلن استئناف العمل في سكه
القطارات بالقرن بعد تعليقه مرتين
من جانب اقاله المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات
الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني نتاليا ان قصف
خطوط امداد القوات الروسيه سيستمر واشارت
لان بلادها التزمت بالتحذير الذي اطلقته
سابقا بان موسم الانفجارات في شبه جزيره
القرم قد حان وفق تعبيرها
لقد حذرنا من ان موسم الانفجارات في شبه
جزيره القرم قدحان ونحن نلتزم بكلمتنا ان
تقدم قواتنا لا يتم فقط على طول الجبهه بل
هو ايضا تحرك في العمق الخلفي للعدو الذي
يشعر حاليا بالقلق واستهداف العمق هو
وسيله لحرمان العدو من امكانياته
اللوجستيه ومن الواضح انه بات يعاني من
ضعف القدره اللوجيسيه على ارسال المعدات
العسكريه او سحبها مستمرون بعمليه القصف
الصاروخي وسنضرب عمق العدو حيث يحتفظ
بمخزونه الاستراتيجي
اذا العمليات العسكريه في البحر الاسود
تتصاعد ومعها يتصاعد القلق من تاثيرها على
سلاسل امداد الغذاء وتوسع السيطره الروسيه
على المنطقه الجيو استراتيجيه سواء
لاوكرانيا او لدول اوروبيه اخرى التكتيكات
العسكريه الروسيه والاوكرانيه في المعركه
نتابعها في التقرير التالي
العالم يقف مشدودا قلقا يراقب التصعيد غير
المسبوق في البحر الاسود نظرا لاهميته
الجيوستراتيجيه بوصفه طريقا رئيسيا
للتجاره الخارجيه للدول المتشاطئه باتجاه
البحر المتوسط ويعد مسارا مهما لتصدير
الطاقه لاسيما لروسيا وطموحاتها بالوصول
الى دول جنوب اوروبا والمياه الدافئه
روسيا تستند في السيطره على البحر الاسود
بتاريخها منذ اواخر القرن الثامن عشر
اتخذت الخطوه الاهم بسيطرتها على شبه
جزيره القرم واعادت ضمها باراضيها لتحافظ
على المقر التاريخي لاسطولها هناك
وفي حربها على اوكرانيا عززت من ترسانتها
لتوسيع هيمنتها وسيطرتها وعماد الترسانه
اسطول حديث متعدد القدرات القتاليه
التقليديه وغير التقليديه ولا تمضي اسابيع
دون ان تعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
ادخال قطع او اسلحه جديده لهذا الاسطول كل
هذه القدرات تضعها روسيا داعما لاي تحرك
لها دون ان تغفل دور الاسلحه الميدانيه
ومنصاتها البحريه استثمار ضخم على المديين
القريب والمتوسط لدعم تحركات الجيش الروسي
البريه فمسك تدرك ان بقائها في شبه جزيره
القرم سيضمن سطوتها على البحر الاسود
ويبقيها على مقربه من المتوسط وبحار اخرى
والبحر الاسود ايضا منطلق روسي لضرب العمق
الاوكراني دون استنزاف ترسانتها الاكثر
حداثه لاسيما ما تسميها موسكو اهدافا
استراتيجيه كمراكز التحكم والقياده
الاوكرانيه البعيده مئات الكيلومترات اما
اوكرانيا التي خسرت تدريجيا مواقعها على
البحر الاسود فتعمل في البحر كما البر
الصليب تكتيكيه غير تقليديه اسلحه توقع
خسائر بليغه لكن دون مواجهه مباشره ومع
ارتفاع نوعيه الدعم العسكري الغربي بدات
الهجمات الاوكرانيه تاخذ منحا اكثر نوعيه
بما يشكل ضغطا وتهديدا على القوات الروسيه
في شبه جزيره القرم وطرق امداد الجيش
الروسي الى المناطق التي اقتطعت من
اوكرانيا سواء عام 2014 او منذ شنه روسيا
الحرب عام
وبهذا يتحول البحر الاسود ايضا مجالا
حيويا عسكريا تتحرك فيه اوكرانيا دون ان
تضطر لان يكون لها قطاع بحريه تقليديه
[موسيقى]
دنا الامين العام للناتو وصفه بمحاوله
موسكو استخدام الغذاء سلاحا وخلال اتصال
مع الرئيس الاوكراني اكد ستمبرغ وقوف
الحلف مع اوكرانيا طالما تطلب الامر ذلك
مشيرا الى انها اقرب الى الناتو منها في
اي وقت مضى حسب تعبيره من ناحيه قال
الرئيس الاوكراني انه حدد مع الامين العام
للناتو الاولويه والخطوات المستقبليه
اللازمه لفتح ممر الحبوب في البحر الاسود
وتشغيله بشكل مستدام
في التطورات الميدانيه ايضا اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه الروسيه عن استهداف القوات
الاوكرانيه بلده في المقاطعه بقذائف
عمقوديه واوضح المسؤول الروسي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت البلده خلال اليوم الماضي
باكثر من عشرين قذيفه من بينها ثلاث قذائف
عنقوديه ادى وحملت السفاره الروسيه في
واشنطن الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه استخدام
هذه الذخائر وقالت ان استخدام كييف
للذخائر العنقوديه ضد المدنيين يثبت ان
واشنطن تفقد السيطره على عملائها
ينضم الينا من شبه جزيره القرم فلاديمير
بيرانوسيان العقيده السابق في القوات
البحريه الروسيه ومن كيافه
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق ومعك
سيد اوليكسي
نبدا هل لنا ان نعرف منك
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه كما تراها والتي
بداتها اوكرانيا في شبه جزيره القرم
مسائكم طيب وشكرا على الدعوه
القرم طالما نظر له
هدفا شرعيا
للقيام بعمليات عسكريه من اوكرانيا منذ
شهر فبراير في عام 22
وكانت اوكرانيا تريد ان تحل مشكله احتلال
القرب بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه خلال اخر ثماني سنوات روسيا
حولت القرب المحتل الى قاعده عسكريه واسعه
المساحه حيث تتمركز الكثير من الذخيره
الاحتياطيه والمعدات واوكرانيا بشكل مستمر
تكرر انه دون القرم من المستحيل ان يكون
هناك نصر حقيقي وهذا يعني ضرو تحرير القر
من الاحتلال الروسي ودون هذا لن يكون هناك
نصر اوكراني حقيقي ولكن هذا ان لكن هذا ما
يقوله المسؤولون الاوكران بشكل متكرر
وسؤالي هنا يعني مرتبط بالتطورات
الميدانيه الانيه التي تحصل في الوقت
الحاضر
بمعنى اخر سؤالي لك لماذا انتظرت اوكرانيا
كل هذه الفتره من بدايه الحرب يعني حوالي
سنه ونصف حتى تدخل شبه جزيره القرم في
ميدان عملياتها العسكريه باختصار
في الواقع هل ضربات في على المراكز
العسكريه في القرن بدات منذ
المراحل الاولى من الحرب في الصيف الماضي
ضربنا
المطارات العسكريه ومراكز تخزين الذخيره
والوقود وهذا كان من الصيف الماضي وفي
الربيع الماضي كان قد تضرر جسر القرم
للمره الاولى وممكن ان لا اتفق معك لان
الضربات كانت منذ البدايه مع العلم ان
المسؤولين الاوكران واخرهم المتحدثه باسم
القياده الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه قالت الان
بدا موسم
الانفجارات في القرن
اسال ضيفي من شبه جزيره القرم السيد
فلاديمير بولسيان
يعني واضح ان روسيا عمليا فشلت في تحييد
هذه المنطقه عن الاستهداف لكن كيف
او هل لديها استراتيجيه معينه للرد ولوقف
الهجمات على القرن بما تشكله من مركز
امداد ومركز لوجستي مهم للمنطقه الجنوبيه
بالنسبه للدفاع عن القرم هنا يجب ان اقول
ان الهجمات بالمسيرات
الطائره التي كانت في
العشرين من هذا الشهر كانت قد اسقطت جميع
المسيرات اما المسيرات المائيه التي التي
استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه الارهابيه ضد
الجسر القرمي فالضرر كانت قليل جدا
وليس هناك اي اعمال عسكريه عن طريق هذا
الجسر لان الاعمال اللوجستيه عن طريق
مرجانز اما بالنسبه
للمنشات المدنيه وكل ما هو في القرن هي
منشاه مدنيه وكما نعلم على الجسر قتلت
اسره زوج وزوجته
لذلك هناك انجرحت ايضا طفله
14 سنه ثم قتلت فيما بعد وهذا النظام في
في اوكرانيا لا يستطيع ان يقوم باي هجمات
ضد مراكز عسكريه فقدوا الكثير من
لكن لكن هو تمكن عفوا هو تمكن من من تفجير
الجسر وهو تمكن من ضرب العديد من المراكز
العسكريه
واليوم هو استهدف مستودع ذخيره يعني هو
يضرب في شبه جزيره القرم المواقع العسكريه
ومستودعات الذخيره
نعم انت محق هذه كانت هجمات على المراكز
في على مركز القرم وفي شهر اكتوبر كان
هناك هجمات قبل هذا وهذه الهجمات تكون
احيانا بحوالي
80% من الهجمات الارهابيه التي تقوم
انظمتنا الدفاعيه الجويه باسقاطها بنجاح
وكون ان بعض هذه المسيرات تصل لبعض
الاهداف هذا لا يؤدي الى اي نصر استراتيجي
للقوات الاوكرانيه لانه هذا لن يؤدي الى
تقدمات
للهجمات المضاده ان هذا ان هذه محاولات
لتشتيت الانتباه بهذه الهجمات الارهابيه
ويريد ان يلفت انتباه ممولوهم الغربيين
انهم لديهم بعض النجاحات علما انه في
المحاور الاساسيه
السيطره وفقدوا حوالي 28 الف جندي ومئات
المعدات من الدبابات
عذرا اسمح لي اعود الى سيد اوليكسي ملك من
من كياب سيد اوليكسي سابقى في منطقه
الجنوب يعني ادخال شبه جزيره القرم بموسم
انفجارات كما تقول هم نيويورك
وتوتير المنطقه بشكل اوسع في في منطقه
الجنوب الا يقضي على الامال بامكانيه عوده
العمل باتفاق الحبوب على اعتبار ان منطقه
البحر الاسود ستصبح منطقه عسكريه
في الواقع
منذ بدايه العدوان الروسي اول ما قامت به
روسيا هو
بدات بحصار بحري لجميع الموانئ الاوكرانيه
والاتفاقات التي وصل لها
بوساطه تركيا كانت قد نقدت لمرات كثيره
وكما نرى الان روسيا تحاول ليس ان تجعل
اوكرانيا تفقد قدرتها على تصدير الحبوب عن
طريق البحر بل تقوم بتدمير البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ واماكن تخزين الحبوب في ميناء
اوديسا وغير وغيره من الموانئ لذلك
اوكرانيا مهتمه
باستخدام البحر لهذه الاهداف الانسانيه
ولكن روسيا اعلنت ان اي سفينه سوف تعتبر
هدفا عسكريا ولذلك هذه قرصنه بحريه على
مستوى دوله لذلك يجب على اوكرانيا ان تبحث
عن وسائل بديله سيدي
ما ردك على هذه النقطه ان ان روسيا هي
التي من عسكرت هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هي
التي اوصلت الامور الى ما وصلت اليه
وانسحبت من من اتفاق نقل الحبوب
واقع واحد اريد ان اقوله لكم
ردا على ما قاله السيد الضيف من كيف
الواقع بالنسبه لاستخدام
اتفاقيه الحبوب
كاساسا
لارسال المسيرات الانتحاريه ضد منشاه
بحريه لقد تم ارسال مسيره كانت هذه
المسيرات قد وصلت في سيفوبيل وبعد استخدام
هذه الاتفاقيه والبنيه والبنيات التحتيه
لتخزين الحبوب لاعمال ارهابيه على هذا
انتهت الاتفاقيه بالنسبه لنا وتركيا
المعتبره احد وسطاء هذا الاتفاق منذ
البدايه كان يجب ان تقوم
بسفن الوضع حراسه حتى تراقب هذه السفن
الاوكرانيه التي كانت تستخدم لاهدافا
ارهابيه وكانوا
يهاجمون سفننا التي كانت تحرس المنطقه
وشكرا وكان ودون هذا من المستحيل ان تستمر
هذه الاتفاقيه لان السفن المدنيه تستخدم
لاعمال
ايرانوسيان العقيده السابق في القوات
البحريه الروسيه من شبه جزيره القرم اشكرك
جزيلا واشكر ايضا
ضيفناك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
الساب
ق اعلنت وكاله ريانوفسكي الروسيه مقتل احد
مراسليها الميدانيين واصابه عدد من زملائه
بقصف اوكراني قالت انه بذخائر عنقوديه
استهدف احدى القرى بمقاطعه زابوروجيا
واتهمت الخارجيه الروسيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه بتعمد استهداف الصحفيين الروس
وقالت ان الدول التي تمد اوكرانيا
بالذخائر العنقوديه تشارك كياف المسؤوليه
عن مقتل الصحفي الروسي
شهدت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا مقتل عدد
من الصحفيين في الثاني والعشرين من شهر
تموز يوليو اعلنت وكاله ريانوفوستي
الروسيه مقتل مراسلها الحربي روستيسلاف
جولاف واصابه عدد من زملائه بقصف اوكرانيا
بضخائر عنقوديه استهدف احدى القرى في
مقاطعه زابوروجيا نهايه شهر مايو ايار قتل
الصحفي الفرنسي فريد
الذي كان يعمل في قناه ام تي في الفرنسيه
وفي العاشر من الشهر نفسه قتل المصور
الفرنسي ارمان سولدا العامل لدى وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه في قصف روسي قرب بخموت
وفق وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
العام الماضي ومع بدايه الحرب في الثالث
والعشرين من شهر مارس اذار قتلت الصحفيه
الروسيه اوكسانا باولينا في قصف روسي على
كييف استنادا الى موقع
الذي كانت تعمل لديه
وكان الصحفي الامريكي الذي عمل سابقا في
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اول صحفي يقتل في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وكان ذلك في
13 من شهر مارس واتهمت الشرطه الاوكرانيه
الجانب الروسي بقتل الصحفي الامريكي في
بلده ايربين في محيط
[موسيقى]
الى التطورات في السودان حيث قال الاعلام
العسكري في الجيش ان قوات الجيش نفذت
عمليه ضد قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
الاسكان قرب حي جبرا جنوب الخرطوم ونشر
الاعلام العسكري صورا تظهر استيلاء قوه
الجيش على سياره عسكريه تابعه للدعم
السريع كما اظهرت الصور وجود قائد السلاح
المدرعات في الجيش اللواء نصر الدين عبد
الفتاح وسط جنود الجيش بعد انتهاء العمليه
العسكريه
وافاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي انفجارات
شمالي ام درمان وكان مصدر عسكري في الجيش
قد قال للجزيره في وقت سابق ان مسيرات
للدعم السريع هجمت اهدافا للجيش في حي
الوادي ووقعت جرحى في صفوفه واضاف المصدر
ان الطائرات الحربيه قصفت اهدافا للدعم
السريع بضاحيه بوري شرقي الخرطوم وفي
ولايه جنوب كردفان قالت مصادر محليه
للجزيره ان قوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال جناح
عبد العزيز الحلو وصلت هجومها لليوم
الثاني غرب مدينه الدلنج بالولايه التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش
مشهد اصبح مالوفا في العاصمه السودانيه
حلقت طائرات الجيش السوداني بكثافه في
سماء العاصمه وتزامن ذلك مع ذوي قصف كثيف
ونيران اسلحه ثقيله وسط الخرطوم وانفجارات
الشمالي ام درمان وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في
وسط المدينه يقول الجيش انه استهدف مواقع
تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه جبرا
جنوبي الخرطوم ويوجد في هذا الحي منزل
لقائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
واظهرت صور انتشار قوات الجيش في الحي
بينما تقول قوات الدعم السريع انها تصدت
لهجمات الجيش وقال مصدر عسكري للجزيره في
وقت سابق ان مسيرات الدعم السريع هاجمت
اهدافا للجيش في حي الوادي بام درمان
واوقعت جرحى في صفوفه من ناحيه اخرى تعيش
مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور
توترا شديدا شل الحركه في المدينه وذلك في
اعقاب القصف المدفعي الكثيف المتبادل بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع يوم الجمعه
وتقول هيئه محامي الولايه ان عددا من
المدنيين قتلوا وجرح اخرون جراء القصف
العشوائي وسقوط القذائف على منازلهم وحذرت
الهيئه من دخول الولايه كلها في حاله فوضى
بعد اخلاء احياء وسط نيالا ونزوح السكان
وتوسع دائره المعارك
وعلى صعيد اخر تتواصل محاولات الحركه
الشعبيه الشمال جناح عبد العزيز الحلو
للسيطره على مواقع جديده في ولايه جنوب
كردفان التي تقود التمرد فيها وذكر انها
وصلت الهجوم على بلده امبرنبيطه غرب مدينه
الدلج المدينه الكبرى الثانيه في الولايه
وان القتال بالاسلحه الثقيله تجدد بضراوه
صباح السبت ما ادى لنزوح المئات نحو
مدينتي ابو كرشوله في الولايه والرهن في
ولايه شمال كردفان المجاوره ظلت الحركه
الشعبيه شمال تستهدف مواقع مختلفه بولايه
جنوب كردفان وكانها تستفيد من واقع البلاد
الراهن وانشغال الجيش فهي لم توقع مع
الحكومه على اتفاق الجباء للسلام المبرم
مع عدد من الحركات المسلحه التي كانت
تحارب نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر حسن البشير
لكنها ابرمت مع الحكومه الحاليه اتفاقا
لوقف اطلاق النار وهو الاتفاق الذي خرقته
في يونيو الماضي وتهاجم منذ اذن مواقع
مختلفه في جنوب كردفان
[موسيقى]
وافادنا مراسلنا قبل قليل بسماع يدوي
انفجارات متقطعه في شمال ام درمان في اطار
العمليات العسكريه المستمره في العاصمه
الخرطوم ومدنها الثلاث نرحب بضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه عيدروس الكاتب
اكاديميه السودانيه المختص في شؤون
السياسيه
والعسكريه مرحبا بك
سيد اسامه
سابدا من ولايه جنوب كردفان
بهجوم قوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال على قوات
الجيش ما الذي يجري هناك
لصالح من هجمات الحركه الشعبيه شمال
بزعامه عبد العزيز الحلو
اولا القتال الداير في السودان الان يعني
من الصعب ان الناس من خارج السودان ان
يعرفوا يعني
ما يجري على الارض حقيقه في السودان لانه
الكلام كله عن هجوم ضربه قتله هجوم ضربا
قتله فالصوره الكليه للصراع غائبه الان
هذا الصراع هو حرب الخرطوم السيطره على
الخرطوم كل هذه الحرب هي حرب السيطره على
الخرطوم اكبر نجاح حقه الدعم السريع انه
نقل الحرب الى الخرطوم لكن هذه الحرب لها
طبقات عده دفرنت او موجوده منهم واحده من
هذه الطبقات العلاقه المتشابكه للحركه
الشعبيه في جبال النوبه وامتدادات حرب
الخرطوم اليها الناظر للحركه الشعبيه يجد
انها لا خلاف اساسي وكبير جدا مع قوات
الدعم السريع يعني خلاف جذري بين الطرفين
وكان متحاربين لفتره طويله جدا طيب الان
هنالك تفسيران التفسير الاول انه هنالك
طرف خارجي قام بالتنسيق بين المجموعتين
دون الافصاح عن تحالف بينهما بين الحركه
الشعبيه الشمال والدعم السريع يعني تم هذا
التحالف بين الطرفين دون الاعلان عنه لانه
سياسيا مكلف للحركه الشعبيه ان تعلن انها
متحالفه مع الدعم السريع لكن
الرؤيه الاخرى ايضا تقول انه الحركه
الشعبيه استغلت انه هنالك مكونات محليه في
جنوب كردفان الان هي موجوده بمقاتليها في
الخرطوم مكونات قبليه من المجتمع المحلي
وهذه المكونات الان افرغت من مقاتليها الى
الخرطوم حتى الحرب نفسها بدات في كادوقلي
والدلنج والحركه الشعبيه وجدت انتقادات
واسعه كما يبدو كما يبدو
القتال يمتد من ولايه الى اخرى من دارفور
الى جنوب
كردفان فضلا عن العاصمه حيث المركز يبقى
هنا سؤال لم يتغير شيء في الواقع العسكري
رغم الهجمات التي يشنها الجيش ويعلنها في
العاصمه لكن الانظار كانت تتجه دائما الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى جده هل هناك
معلومات ان كان هناك اي شيء على مستوى
التفاوض
طيب اكمل نقطه الحركه الشعبيه واتيك الى
كلها مرتبطه مع بعض بيختصار الان الحركه
الشعبيه بعد ان كانت تهاجم الدلنج
وكادوغلي انتقلت الى الجبال الشرقيه
موجوده في الجبال الغربيه وهي اماكن لمكون
من اهلنا النوبه اللي هي المكونه الرئيسي
للحركه الشعبيه نفسها فوجدت انتقادات
واسعه لهجومها على هاتين المدينتين انتقلت
الى مكانا مكونات يمكن ان نقول عليها
المكونات العربيه من قبيله الحوازمه
الموجوده في ابكرشولا وهذا لانه افرغت هذه
المنطقه من المقاتلين ذهبوا للقتال
السياسي باختصار الجانب السياسي ما اقول
لك استاذ حسن انه حتى الان لم يرشح شيء من
المفاوضات الدائره في جده لكن هذه
المفاوضات الجيش وضع فيها نقاط واضحه
الخروج من بيوت المواطنين
الخروج من المستشفيات الخروج من الخرطوم
الى خارجه هذا يعني للدعم السريع نهايه
الحرب لذلك لم يصلوا الى اتفاق متى سيصل
الى اتفاق عندما يبدا الدعم السريع في
مصالح الحقيقيه
امواله اشكرك جزيلا دكتور اسامه ال عذرا
انتهى ضيفنا الاكاديمي
والبحث السياسي الدكتور اسامه شكرا جزيلا
بدات السلطات في تشاد نقل اللاجئين
السودانيين من المخيم المؤقت بمنطقه ادري
الى مخيم اخر في قريه اورنج التي تبعد عن
الحدود التشاديه السودانيه نحو 30
كيلومترا وتقول السلطات التداعيات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه لوجود اللاجئين في ادرى كبيره
جدا
من مخيم الى اخر ذاك قدر الاف اللاجئين
السودانيين في تشاد امونه التي لجات الى
ادري وجدت نفسها مضطره للمغادره الى مخيم
جديد بجانب قريه اورانج يبعد نحو 30
كيلومترا عن الحدود التاليه السودانيه
انجبت امونه قبل ايام وهي من بين اللاجئين
السودانيين ممن عادوا الى بلادهم قبل عشر
سنوات
لكنها فرت منها مجددا
وحاجاتها الى التنقل والحمايه متواصله
بس تعبانين وانا ولدت بعمليه شيء ناكل
ذاته معي ازداد عدد اللاجئين فلم تعد
المنظمات الانسانيه قادره على توفير
الاحتياجات الاساسيه
بسبب قله الموارد وقرب نفاد مخزونها من
المساعدات
نريد ان نوقف ما يحدث الاطفال يموتون هم
يموتون بالفعل وليس سيموتون علينا ان
نساعدهم
وصل الى ادرى حتى الان نحو تسعين الف لاجئ
هم اكثر من ضعف عدد سكانها البالغين نحو
اربعين الفا ترى السلطات التجاريه في
وجودهم تحديا امنيا واقتصاديا لهذه
المحافظه الحدوديه
ادري لا تستطيع تحمل هذا الامر تسبب طالب
اللجوء في غلاء المعيشه واثروا كذلك على
الوضع الصحي والامني في الايام المقبله
ومع نقلهم الى المخيمات ربما تعود الحياه
الى طبيعتها
الارض الممنوحه لمخيم اورنج تتسع لنحو نصف
عدد اللاجئين الذين ينقلون من المخيم
المؤقت بمدينه ادريس
الى هنا في اورنج وهو ما يبين حاجه
السلطات الى توفير اكثر من موقع
لاقامه اللاجئين الذين ما يزالون يتدفقون
الى تشات هنا على بعد نحو ثلاثه كيلومترات
من مدينه ادريس هذا الموقع للايواء المؤقت
للضعفاء من المرضى واللاجئين المسنين
لكن عدد ساكنيه تجاوز قدرته الاستيعابيه
فتوقف عن استقبال اللاجئين جدد فضل عبد
الرزاق الجزيره
ادريه من الحدود الكاديه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
بالاوضه مشاهدينا الى طلب الرئيس
الاوكراني من النيتو فتح ممر للحبوب في
البحر الاسود
وحمايه طلب زيلينسكي بل طلب زيلينس في هذا
ياتي بعد ايام قليله من قرار روسيا عدم
تمديد العمل بالاتفاقيه الرباعيه وتفاصيل
قليله المتاحه بشان طلب الاوكراني من
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي هو ان
يستغل ويشتغل بالممر بشكل مستدام كانت
عمليه التصدير بموجب الاتفاقيه تتم عبر
ثلاثه موانئ اوكرانيا وهي اوديسا ويوجني
وتشورنو
وتشم موسكو منذ عده ايام ضربات واسعه
باسلحه جويه وبحريه من البحر الاسود على
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب ميناء يوديسا
جنوب غربي اوكرانيا كما اعلنت كييف ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت ميناء تشيرنو
موسكو قرب اوديسا وان احدى ضربات دمرت 60
الف طن من الحبوب المخزنه في الميناء
والمخصصه للتصدير واستنادا لمصادر في
صناعه التامين فان شركات التامين شركات
تامين كثيره علقت الان توفير غطاء للشحنات
القادمه من اوكرانيا على خلاف الموانئ
الاصغر على طول نهر الدلو
[موسيقى]
بررت موسكو عدم تمديدها للاتفاقيه
الرباعيه لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
البحر الاسود
بعدم احترام اجزاء من الاتفاق تسمح بتصدير
الاغذيه والاسمده الروسيه وكانت الاتفاقيه
التي ولدت بعد مفاوضات شاقه قد وقعت في
اسطنبول في يوليو 2022 بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بواسطه تركيا والامم المتحده
وكانت روسيا قد علقت العمل بالاتفاق في 29
من اكتوبر عام 2022 على خلفيه تفجير
الجانب الاوكراني لجسر القرد
تراجعت روسيا عن هذا القرار في الثاني من
نوفمبر 2022 عقب مباحثات بين الجانبين
التركي والروسي ادت الى ضمانات جديده تنص
على عدم التعرض للاسطول الروسي او
المساسبه
في الثالث عشر من مارس 2023 اعلنت
الخارجيه الروسيه موافقتها على تمديد
الاتفاق لمده 60 يوما فقط بدلا من 120
يوما على ان ينتهي العمل بها في شهر مايو
مددت بعدها الاتفاقيه للمره الثالثه حتى
تاريخ 17 من يوليو الجاري وبعدها توقف
العمل بها في انتظار نتائج جهود الوساطه
التركيه لاحيائها
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
وارسو الجنرال المتقاعد ييرسلاف
كنائب رئيس
مديريه الاستخبارات في حلف الناتو سابقا
والمدير السابق للابحاث في المخابرات
العسكريه
البولنديه مرحبا بك سيد يارسلاظ
لنبدا من طلب الرئيس زيلينسكي هل بالامكان
تلبيه هذا الطلب انشاء ممر امن لنقل
الحبوب بمعزل عن روسيا وقوتها العسكريه في
البحر الاسود
اذا نظرنا من منظور العلاقات الدوليه حيث
ان الرئيس بوتين
ومن خلال
هذه الاستفزازات وهذه التهديدات ضد اي سفن
تتوجه الى اوديسا يحاول ان ينقل هذه الحرب
الى مستوى اخر من التدوين
من خلال
وضع
خطوطا حمراء لقوه حلف شمال الاطلسي ومن
خلال حظره تصدير الحبوب الى الجنوب يريد
ان يخلق ازمه اخرى ربما لكي يسبب بتدفق
جديدا للاجئين الى اوروبا
اذا هذه هي الازمه على مستويات عده ولكنه
تحرك ذكي من قبل الرئيس بوتين السؤال هو
كيف يمكن ان يحصل ذلك او هل هذا ممكن وهل
سوف ينجح ما هذا ما سالتك اياه قلت بان
الممر ممكن انشاؤه لكن كيف يتم انشاؤه
ولماذا لم ينشا قبل تلك الاتفاقيات وقبل
ان تستغل روسيا هذه الاتفاقيات
حتى من المعلومات التي عرضتموها
فالاتفاقيه السنه الماضيه قد حصلت بوساطه
تركيه وهي لاعب وطرف ناشط في هذا المجال
كما اسلفت من الممكن فتح هذا الممر من قبل
النيتو ولكن هذا بالغ الصعوبه لان الناتو
ليس جزءا من هذا النزاع هو طبعا يدعم
اوكرانيا من خلال التجهيزات والمعدات
والموارد الماليه ودعم الماليه ولكن
للحصول على موافقه تامه ومشاركه تامه
وكامله من حلف شمال اطلسيه في هذه الحرب
هذا امر بالغ الصعوبه ولهذا السبب يلعب
بوتين هذه الورقه من اجل التسبب
ازمه داخل النيتو ولكن هذا يؤثر على
الاقتصاد الاوكراني امر مهم يعني افهم منك
افهم منك بان تلبيه طلب الرئيس زيلينسكي
من الناتو انشاء هذا الممر الامن بمعزل عن
روسيا معناه مشاركه من الناتو مباشره في
الحرب ويصبح طرفا مباشرا في الحرب
هذا ممكن نعم ولكن السؤال الرئيسي هو هل
من الممكن فعلا
لبوتين ان يشرك قواته البحريه من اجل ان
يوجه الضربه
لاي سفينه دوليه تتوجه نحو اوديسا هنا
يكمن السؤال الرئيسي طبعا الممر الامن ضمن
المياه الدوليه
لا يجب ان يكون اي مشكله بموجب القانون
الدولي ولكننا نعلم ان رئيس بوتين يضرب
عدل الحائط بهذا القانون الدولي شكرا لك
يا
روسبوزيك الجنرال المتقاعد ونائب رئيس
مديريه الاستخبارات في حلف الناتو سابقا
حدثنا من وارسو
لهذا ينتهي الحصاد لهذه الليله تصبحون على
الف خير
[موسيقى]